14th
most common question asked by the
non-Muslim regarding Islam is why does
Islam prohibit a Muslim from having
alcohol?
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala says in the
glorious Quran in surah maida chapter
number 5 verse number 19
oh you believe
most certainly intoxicant and gambling
dedication of stones divination of
arrows
these are satiwork
abstain from this handiwork that you may
prosper so Allah is telling telling you
oh you believe most certainly
intoxicates anything which intoxicates
alcohol wine whiskey drug anything which
intoxicates
abstain from it
these are Satan's handwork abstain from
it that you may prosper and the same
message is even mentioned in the Bible
it's mentioned in the Bible in the book
of proverbs chapter number 20 verse
number one it says wine is a mocker
strong drink is raging
whoever is deceived by it is unwise
a similar message is repeated in the
book of Ephesians chapter number 5 verse
number 18 do not be drunk with wine
that means for the Jews and for the
Christians
consuming alcohol is prohibited
it's also prohibited the Hindu scripture
If you read Manusmitti chapter number
two verse number 228 and various other
verses it says that you should not drink
alcohol. All those who drink alcohol
they are sinners.
Let us analyze what are the logical and
scientific reasons why almighty God
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has prohibited
the human being from having intoxicants
from having alcohol.
Today science tells us that the human
brain has an inhibitory center.
Inhibitory center means this inhibitory
center prevents you from doing things
which are not correct. For example, if I
want to go to the call of nature, my
inhibitory center will say don't do it
here.
Go to the restroom. Go to the washroom.
Go to the toilet. Because my inhibitor
center works when I'm speaking with
elderly people. Inhibitive center say
speak with them with respect. When I'm
speaking with my parents, oh don't use
vulgar language with your parents. The
inhibitive center is working because
they are your parents. Now when you have
intoxicants this inhibitive center is
inhibited. So you see very often those
who are drunk they urinate
in their clothes in their trousers. Many
of times you you find them arguing and
using vulgar language with with other
people. Many of times when they speak
with their parents who are elderly, they
even abuse them because they're drunk.
The inhibitive center is inhibited.
So if we analyze
cases of molestation
of rape of incest and AIDS increase with
those who are alcoholic
according to the national crime
the national
crime survey bureau of justice also
known as US department of justice
in the year 2014 alone every day on an
average 2,318
cases of rape took place. That means
every 37 seconds one rape is taking
place and investigation tells us in most
of these cases majority
the person who does the crime is
intoxicated.
Similarly, when molestation takes place,
the person who molest most often he's
intoxicated.
Statistics tell us in USA alone, 8% of
the American population, they do incest.
Incest mean having sexual relationship,
mother and son, father and daughter,
brother and sister. Incest. 8% EVERY
12TH American you meet,
he's committing incest.
And research tells us that either one or
both of them in most cases
they're intoxicated.
So by having alcohol high chances of
molestation, of rape, of incest, and
even aid, which is a dangerous disease,
scientific evidence says that there are
more chances of you having aid if you
alcoholic.